الان الى المانيا حيث لا تزال حادثه
محاوله الانقلاب في الواجهه رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه توماس
احاد قال ان بلاده وجه الضربه قويه لتنظيم
مواطن الرايخ في مقابله مع قناه
الالمانيه كشف ان اعضاء من التنظيم جاؤوا
من الجيش الالماني ويمتلكون مهارات القوات
الخاصه فضلا عن امتلاكههم اسلحه من
مخزونات الجيش
كان ضربه قويه لمجموعه مواطنين رايح
المسلحه والتي يبلغ عدد اتباعها 21000 شخص
ارتكبت هذه المجموعه اكثر من 1000 جريمه
العام الماضي ونحن يراقبها منذر بيع هذا
العام ونعرف مخططاتها مجموعه مواطنين
بالاسلحه والعديد من افرادها يمتلكنا
قانونيه او غير قانونيه ومن مخزونات الجيش
الالمانيه
ولديهم المهارات المناسبه من خلال خدمتهم
في الوحدات الخاصه العسكريه
موقعا جديدا ويتوقع ان تكون موجه اعتقالات
جديده
بينهم جنود سابقون ينتمون الى جماعه من
اقصى اليمين بتهمه الاعداد اسقاط الدوله
وخانت الحكومه الى المجموعه كانت تنوي
لاستيلاء على السلطه بالقوه وان شاء جيشا
موازن وتنفيذ هجمات داخل المانيا
ودراسه الادله التي جمعت في هذه المداهمات
زادت من عدد المشتبه بتورطهم في هذه
المؤامره الى اربعه وخمسين شخصا
ينضم الان الينا من برج الجنوبيه المانيا
مراسلنا عيسى الطيبي ومن برلين مراسلنا
اسد الله الصاوي اهلا بكما عيسى واسد الله
وابدا بعد معك عيسى همم يعني انت في
بافاريا في مقر همم مواطن الرايخ او هكذا
كان يعتقد ولكن واضح ان همم اثارهم وهمم
المشاركه في صفوفهم ممتدت الى اكثر من
الولايات الان
قل الجيش على الخط كما اعلن همم وزير
استخبارات السابق ورئيس الاستخبارات هل
هذا يعني ان هناك اعضاء
حاليون او حاليين في الجيش الان منخرطون
في صفوف مواطنين الرخ ام الامر مقتصر على
اعضاء سابقين في الجيش
علمتها وزاره الدفاع الالماني والمتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه ان الضابطه
الصف
يعد واحد من اهم القياديين في التنظيم
ايضا ايضا مقدم في في الجيش الالماني في
القوه الخاصه واحد مؤسس قوه الخاصه الفار
من من الجيش الالماني وهو مؤسس اصلا في
هذا التنظيم العسكري الجديد الكثير من ااه
من جنود الاحتياط ايضا الاعضاء في التنظيم
لذلك التحقيقات الاوليه للاستخبارات
العسكريه دلت على وجود واختراق لهذا
التنظيم في صفوف قوه الخاصه نتذكر جيدا لي
انه قبل اشهر قليله تم الاعلان عن اختراق
لليمين المتطرف واهم جيوب اليمين المتطرف
هي هي هو تنظيم مواطن الرايخ لي القوات
الخاصه بماذا لحلها بالكامل بشكل دراما
تيكي لذلك هذا الامر وجود قوات او وجود
جنود من الجيش الالماني وجود جنود احتياط
من الجيش الالماني وجود جنود سابقين من
الجيش الالماني في صفوف التنظيم باتت
حقيقه واقعه بل اكثر من ذلك الان
الاستخبارات تتحدث بان اجزاء من سلاح هذا
التنظيم هي من مخزونات الجيش الالماني
وهذه السابقه خطيره لربما ارجع ايضا الى
رمزيه المكان الذي يقف فيه في نيويورك
التي تعاد ثاني اكبر مدينه في ولايه هي
معقل لهذا التنظيم ولايه بلغاريا طبعا هي
اكثر عدد من المنتسب لهذا التنظيم لكن هي
تعد واحد من عاقل التنظيم القويه جدا
والتي تنظر اليها الاستخبارات وتنظر اليها
هيئه حمايه الدستور بعين الرصد والمتابعه
همم ما اعلنه النائب العام ايضا عن حمله
هنا في نيرومبرج ادت الاعتقال بما وصفته
قياديين في التنظيم ويعتقد بانهم قياديين
في الذراع العسكري لهذا التنظيم ايضا وزير
الداخليه البافاري
يواخر النهار من اعلن بان بان 16 شخص تم
لغايه هذه اللحظه اعتقالهم بان هذه
العمليه شمله
منطقه
كله هذه المناطق هذه المنطقه مما يعني بان
التنظيم يضرب بقوه ومتغلغل في هذه المنطقه
للتسكير ايضا بان قياديين من التنظيم
بارين همم تم القبض على احدهما في منطقه
بيروجيا بايطاليا والثاني تم القبضه عليه
واعتقاله في منطقه كيس فول في النمسا
وبالتالي يعتقد بان تفريخ هذا التنظيم
ياتي من هذا المكان الذي يقف فيه من منطقه
فهي رمزيه تاريخيه ايضا
تذكرني الى بان محاكم النازيه محاكم
قيادات النازيه ايضا كانت في هذا المكان
لذلك كان دائما الحديث بان مواطنه الرايخ
يعتقدون بانهم امتداد الفتره لفتره الرايق
الثالث ويقصد بها انا هنا هي الفتره
النازيه نعم ابقى معنا عيسى اسد الله
الصاوي من برلين على على المستوى الاتحادي
همم هل تبدو ان هناك همم او يبدو انه هناك
تغيير في طريقه تعامل اصلطات الالمانيه
الاتحاديه مع مواطني الرايخ في ضوء ما كشف
حتى الان وتوسع عمليات المداهمه والاعتقال
لقياديين واعضاء في هذه المنظمه
نعم حسن ما يرجح عن السلطات الالمانيه حتى
الان يشير الى تركيز الضوء بشكل كبير على
هذا التنظيم تنظيم مواطنين الرايخ سيما
بعد المعلومات التي يتسربت انهم كانوا
يعني اقتربوا الى حد كبير لم يحدد بالضبط
من قبل السلطات من تنفيذ المخطط
لعمل الانقلاب في هذه البلاد في المانيا
همم وكيل البرلمان الالماني ااه يعني اسفل
القبه التي ترونها في خلفيه الصوره ان هذا
بالامس وطالبه بتشديد الحراسه الامنيه على
مقر الانسنه البرلمان الالماني هذا كله
يعني يظهر انه لم تظهر الشرطه نوع من
تشديد الاجراءات الامنيه لا ترى همم مساء
مثلا عناصر للشرطه سواء مسلحون او همم ام
لا تراهم في الشوارع لا تراهم حول المقرات
الامنيه بشكل اكثر من همم
المعتاد اا ما يثير القلق في هذا
التنظيم بالنتس ب- لكثير من المراقبين هو
بالنسبه لبعض المواطنين هو ان التنظيم
انتشر في قطاعات مختلفه ربما في الجيش
وهناك اا انباء عن الاستيلاء على كميات
كبيره همم من الاسلحه ولكن ايضا في قطاعات
اخرى همم يعني عضوه سابقه في هذا البرلمان
الالماني عن حزب البديل من اجل المانيا
وقاضيه في همم همم
القضاء الالماني عضو في هذا التنظيم تم
تعليق عضويتها في القضاء ولكن ما يقلق
بالنسبه للكثيرين هنا ان هذه القاضيه
اقسمت مرتين قطاع القضاء في اطار عملها او
في البرلمان على احترام الدستور ها هي
الان نعم نحول
الدوله الالمانيه
ومن همم برج شكرا